- [Instructor] What we
have here is the graph
of R is equal to sin of two
theta in polar coordinates
and if polar coordinates
look unfamiliar to you
or if you need to brush up on them
I encourage you to do a
search for polar coordinates
in Khan Academy or look at
our pre-calculus section
but I'll give you a little
bit of a primer here.
Let's just familiarize ourself
why this graph looks the way it does.
So, what we're doing for any point here,
we could obviously specify these points
in terms of X and Y coordinates
but we could also specify
them in terms of an angle
and a radius so for example,
this would have some X coordinate
and some Y coordinate
or we could draw a line
from the origin to that
point right over here
and specify it with some angle theta
and some R which is the distance
from the origin to that point.
And just to familiarize ourselves
with this curve
let's just see why it's intuitive.
So, when theta is zero,
R is going to be zero,
sin of two times zero is just zero,
so our R we're just gonna be at the origin
and then as theta get larger,
our R gets larger
and so, we start tracing out
this pedal of this flower
or clover-looking thing,
so it starts looking like that
and we could keep going all the way.
What happens when theta
is equal to pi over four?
When theta is equal to pi
over four right over there,
well, sin of two times pi over four
is sin of pi over two,
R is equal to one.
So, we reach a kind of a maximum R there
and then and as theta increases,
our R once again starts to get smaller
and smaller and smaller.
Now, we're going to do
this in a calculus context,
so the first question might be
well, how do we express
the rate of change of R
with respect to theta?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure it out.
What is R prime of theta?
Well, there's really nothing new here.
You just have one variable
as a function of another.
You just use the chain rule.
Take the derivative with respect to theta
right over here.
So, the derivative of sin of two theta
with respect to two theta
is going to be cosine
of two theta
and then you multiply that,
times the derivative of two theta
with respect to theta which is two,
so we could just say times two here
or we could write a two out front.
Alright, that was interesting
but let's see if we can express this curve
in terms of Xs and Ys
and then think about those derivatives.
So, one primer, a review from pre-calculus
is that when you wanna go
between the polar world
and the, I guess you can
say rectangular world,
you have to remember the transformation
that Y is equal to R sin of theta
and that X is equal to R cosine of theta.
Now, just as a really quick primer,
why does that make sense?
Well, let's just take one of
these angle R combinations
right over here,
so let's say this is
theta and that is our R.
Well, the height of that side
is going to by our Y
and then the length of this side
is going to be our X.
Well, we know from trigonometry
from our unit circle definition,
the SOHCAHTOA definition
of our trig functions,
sin of theta is opposite over hypotenuse,
sin of theta is equal
to Y over our hypotenuse
which is R and cosine of theta
is equal to the adjacent or X over R
and you just have multiply both sides
of these equations by R
to get to what we have right over there
and once again, if this is going too fast,
this is a review
of just polar coordinates
from pre-calculus.
But now we can use these to express
purely in terms of theta.
How do we do that?
Well, we know that R is
equal to sin of two theta,
so you just have to replace these Rs
with sin of two theta.
So, Y would be equal to sin of two theta,
sin of two theta times sin of theta,
times sin of theta
and X is going to be
equal to sin of two theta,
sin of two theta
times cosine of theta,
times cosine of theta, just like that
but now we can use these expressions
to find the rate of change
of Y with respect to theta,
find a general expression for it.
Pause the video and
see if you can do that.
Right, let's work through it together.
Well, this is once again,
we're just gonna use our
derivative techniques,
so I could write Y prime of theta,
the derivative of Y with respect to theta,
just gonna use the product
rule right over here,
derivative of this first expression
is two cosine of two theta,
cosine of two theta,
we've already seen that.
That's just coming out of the chain rule
and then times the second expression,
sin of theta
and then plus, plus the first expression,
sin of two theta,
sin of two theta
times the derivative of
the second expression,
derivative of the sin of
theta is cosine of theta.
Fair enough and we could
do the same thing for X.
X prime of theta,
derivative of the first expression,
it is going to be two
times cosine of two theta,
two times cosine of two theta,
times the second expression,
cosine of theta
and then you're gonna
have the first expression,
sin of two theta,
times the derivative of
the second expression
which is negative sin of theta,
negative sin of theta
and we could use this,
we could actually
evaluate these at points.
For example, we could say
well, what's happening
when theta is equal to pi over four?
So, when theta's pi over four,
I'll do that in black right over here.
We are going to be at this point
right over there.
Well, let's evaluate it.
So, if I were to say Y prime
of pi over four is equal to, let's see,
this is going to be equal to two cosine
of pi over two, two times pi over four,
times sin of pi over four
plus sin of two times pi over four
is sine of pi over two
times cosine of pi over four.
Cosine of pi over four.
What is this going to be equal to?
Well, cosine of pi over two is zero,
so if that's zero all of
this stuff's gonna be zero
and here's sin of pi over two,
this is one, cosine of pi over four
is square root of two over two,
square root of two over two,
so this is going to be equal
to square root of two over two
and actually just for the
sake of saving some space
I'll just write it right over here.
It's going to be equal to
square root of two over two.
Well, we could do the
same exercise with X.
We could say X prime of pi over four.
Let's see.
We're still gonna have
two times cosine of two
times pi over four,
so that's going to be two
times cosine of pi over two.
This first part right over
here is gonna look the same,
so that first term's gonna be zero.
Then we're gonna have minus,
so this is all gonna be zero,
so then we're gonna have minus sin
of pi over two times pi over four
is sin of pi over, sin of pi over two,
and then times sin of pi over four,
sin of pi over four.
Now, this is just going to be one
and so, this is gonna be equal to
and this is square root
of two over two as well,
so this is negative square
root of two over two.
Now let's see why that that makes sense.
So, let's think about what happens
as theta increases here.
If you increase theta a little bit
from pi over four,
if you increase it just a little bit,
your Y coordinate continues to increase,
so it makes sense you have
a positive slope here.
But what happens to your X coordinate
as theta increases a little bit,
as theta goes from there to there?
Well, then your X coordinate
starts to decrease
when theta increases,
so that's why it makes sense
that you have a negative rate of change
right over here.
Now, the next question that you might say
is say is well, I wanna
find the rate of change
of Y with respect to X
because I want to figure out the slope
of the tangent line right over there.
And it looks like it has
a slope of negative one
but how would we actually calculate it?
Well, one way to think about it is
the derivative of Y,
the derivative Y with respect to X
is going to be equal
to the derivative of Y
with respect to theta
over the derivative of X
with respect to theta.
And so, at that value,
so at theta is equal to pi over four,
this is going to be equal
to positive square root
of two over two
over negative square root of two over two,
negative square root of two over two
and this all simplifies to
being equal to negative one,
which makes sense.
This does look indeed like a tangent line
that has a slope of negative one.
So, hopefully this puts it altogether,
you're feeling a little
bit more comfortable,
you got a review a little bit
of the polar coordinates
but we've augmented that knowledge
by starting to take some derivatives.